Mm, Gradle, mm, Gradle.
>> Jeremy, Jeremy.
>> [COUGH] Hey, Mark.
What's up?
>> Yeah, I thought you were supposed
to release your Android app today.
What's all of this?
>> Oh, I've just got to use Android's
Studio wizard to generate my signed APK
today, so
I'm just doing my wizard ritual.
I hope it all works right.
>> A wizard?
>> Yeah, you never really know what
those build wizards are doing, right?
So, you just gotta hope
nothing goes wrong.
>> You know a wizard
isn't actually magic.
>> Oh yeah?
Well,
how does it generate its magical keys
and magically spit out a signed APK?
>> There's nothing magic about it.
Android Studio can't do anything that
you can't do from the command line.
>> Oh yeah?
Yeah.
Android Studio,
all it was doing is telling
Gradle to run some tasks.
And those tasks are just using
regular command line utilities.
>> So, it's not magic?
>> No.
>> And I don't have to wear
this robe to get it to work?
>> Oh, thank god, this is so hot.
[SOUND] Help me get this thing off.
Oh, I never should have trusted that
centaur I met in the mystical forest.
I shouldn't have paid him 50 gold
pieces for programming advice.